if you ask evolutionary biologists when
did humans became humans some of them
will say that well at some point we
started standing on our feet we came
biped and became the masters of our
environment others will say that because
our brain started growing much bigger
that were able to have much more complex
cognitive processes and others might
argue that it's because we developed a
language that allowed us to evolve as a
species interestingly those three
phenomena are all connected we're not
sure how or in which order but they are
all linked with the change of shape of
little bone in the back of your neck
that change the angle between our head
and our body that made that were able to
stand upright but also for a brain to
evolve in the back and for Voicebox to
grow from 7 centimeters for primates to
11 and up to 17 centimeters for humans
and this is called add essence of the
lungs and the larynx is a site of your
voice when baby humans are born today
their larynx is not descended yet that
only happened at about 3 months old so
metaphorically each of us here I've
relived the evolution of our whole
specie and talking about babies when you
were starting to develop in your
mother's womb the first sensation that
you had coming from the outside world at
only 3 weeks old when you are about the
size of a shrimp we're through the
tactile sensation coming from the
vibrations of your mother's voice so as
we can see the human voice is quite
meaningful and important at the species
at the level of the species at the level
of the society
this is how we communicate and create
bonds and at the personal and
interpersonal levels with our voice
which are much more than words and data
this is which we share basically who we
are and our voice is indecisive or from
how other people see us it is a mask
that we were in society but our
relationship with our own voice is far
from obvious we rarely use our voice for
our self we use it as a gift to give to
others it is a how we touch each other
it's a dialectical grooming but what do
we think about our own voice so please
raise your hand if you don't like the
sound of your voice when you hear it on
recording machine yeah thank you indeed
most people report not liking the sound
of their of their voice recording so
what does that mean let's try to
understand that in the next 10 minutes
I'm a researcher at the MIT Media Lab
part of the opera the Future group and
my my research focuses on the
relationship people have with their own
voice and with the voices of others I
study what we can learn from listening
to voices from different various fields
from neurology to biology cognitive
sciences linguistic and in our group we
create tools and experiences to help
people gain a better applied
understanding of their voice in order to
reduce the biases to become better
listeners to create more healthy
relationship or just to understand
themselves better and this really has to
come with a holistic approach on the
voice because think about all the
applications and implications that the
voice might have as we discover more
about it your voice is a very complex
phenomena it it requires a
synchronization of more than 100 muscles
in your body and by listening to the
voice we can understand possible
failures of what happens inside
for example listening to very specific
type of turbulences and non linearity of
the voice can help predict very earliest
of parking Sun just to a phonecall
listening to the breath nests of the
voice can help detect heart disease and
we also know that the changes of tempo
inside individual words is a very good
marker of depression your voice is also
very linked with your hormone levels
third part is listening to female voices
were able to very accurately place the
speaker on their menstrual cycle just
with acoustic informations and now with
technologies listening to us all the
time
Amazon Alexa from Amazon echo might be
able to predict if you're pregnant even
before you know it so think about it
think about the ethical application of
that your voice is also very linked to
how you create relationship you have a
different voice for every person you
talk to if I take a little snippet of
your voice and I analyze it I can know
whether you're talking to your mother to
your brother your friend or your boss we
can also use as a predictor as a vocal
posture meaning how you decide to place
your voice when you talk to someone and
you vocal posture when you talk to your
spouse can help predict not only if but
also when you will divorce so there is a
lot to learn from listening to voices
and I believe that this has to start
with understanding that we have more
than one voice so I'm going to talk
about three voices that most of us
possess in a model of what I call the
mask so when you look at a mask what you
see is a projection of a character let's
call that your outward voice this is
also the most classic way to think about
the voice it's a way of projecting
yourself in the world the mechanism for
this projection is well understood your
lung contract your diaphragm that
creates a self-sustained vibration of
your vocal folds that creates a sound
and then the way you open and close the
cavities in your mouth your vocal tract
is going to transform the sound so
everyone has the same mechanism but
voices are quite unique it's because
very subtle differences
sighs in Physiology in hormone levels
are gonna change it's going to make very
several differences in your outward
force a new brain is very good at
picking up those subtle differences from
other people's outward voices in our lab
we're working on teaching machines to
understand those subtle differences and
really we use deep learning to create a
real-time speaker identification system
to help raise awareness on the shared of
on the use of the shared vocal space so
who talks and who never talks during
meetings to increase group intelligence
and one of the difficulties with that is
that your voice is also not static we
already said that it changes with every
person you talk to but it also changes
generally throughout your life at the
beginning and at the end of the journey
male and female voices are very similar
it's very hard to distinguish the voice
of a very young girl from the voice of a
very young boy but in the between your
voice become a marker of your fluid
identity and generally for male voices
there is a big change at puberty and
then for female voices there is a change
at each pregnancy and a big change at
menopause so all of that is the voice
other people hear when you talk so why
is it that we are so unfamiliar with it
why is it that it's not the voice that
we hear so let's think about it when you
were a mask you actually don't see the
mask and when you try to observe it what
you will see is inside of the mask and
that's your inward voice so to
understand why it's different let try to
understand the mechanism of perception
of this inward voice because your body
has many ways of filtering it
differently from the outward voice so to
perceive this voice it first has to
travel to your ears and your outward
voice travels through the air while your
inward voice travels through your bones
this is called bone conduction and
because of this your inward voice is
going to sound in a lower register and
also more musically harmonically
harmonically than your outward voice
once it travels there it has to access
your inner ear and there is a certain
mechanism taking place here it's a it's
a mechanical filter it's a little
partition that comes and protects your
inner ear and each time you produces a
sound so that also reduces what you hear
and then there is a third filter it's a
biological filter you're in your cochlea
it's a part of your inner ear that
processes the sound is made out of
living cells and those living cells are
going to trigger it differently
according to how often they hear the
sound
it's an arbitration effect so because of
this as your voice is a sound you hear
the most in your life you actually hear
it less than all the sounds
finally we have a force filter it's a
neurological filter neurologists found
out recently that when you open your
mouth to create a sound your own
auditory cortex shuts down so you hear
your voice but your brain actually never
listens to the sound of your voice
well if Ellucian early that might make
sense because we know cognitively what
we're gonna sound like so maybe we don't
need to spend energy analyzing the
signal and this is called a corollary
discharge and this happened for every
motion that your body does the exact
definition of a corollary discharge is a
copy of a motor command that is sent by
the brain this copy doesn't create any
motion itself but instead is sent to
other regions of the brain to inform
them of the impending motion and for the
voice this corollary discharge also has
a different name it is your inner voice
so let's recapitulate we have the masks
outward voice the inside of the mask
your inward voice and then you have your
inner voice and I like to see this one
as the puppeteer that holds the strings
of the whole system and your inner voice
is so when you hear when you read a text
silently when you rehearse for an
important conversation
sometime it's hard to turn it off right
is really hard to look at the text
written in your native language without
having this inner voice with it it also
the voice that refuses to stop singing
this stupid song you have in your head
and for some people it's actually
impossible to control it and that the
case of schizophrenic patients who have
auditory hallucinations who can't
distinguish at all between voices coming
from inside and outside the head so in
our lab we are also working on small
devices to help those people make those
distinction and know if the voice is
internal or external you can also think
about the inner voice as the voice that
speak in your dream this inner voice can
take many forms and in your dreams you
actually unleash the potential of this
inner voice that's another work we are
doing in our lab trying to access this
inner voice in twins so even if you
can't always control it the inner voice
you can always engage with it through
dialogue through inner dialogue and you
can even see this inner voice as the
missing link between salts and actions
so I hope I've left you with a better
appreciation a new appreciation of all
of your voices and the roles it plays
inside and outside of you as for your
voice is a very critical determinant of
what makes you humans and of how you
interact with the world thank you